I felt like a tornado of emotion Simone
biles speaks out for the first time
since her brother was charged with
multiple counts of murder
et confirmed on Friday that the 22 year
old Olympic phenoms brother
Tevin biles Thomas was arrested on
multiple felony charges including murder
in the shooting deaths of three men at a
New Year's Eve party in Ohio
Simone took to Twitter Monday night to
share with her fans that she's still
having a hard time processing last
week's news she shared a statement that
read quote my heart aches for everyone
involved especially for the victims and
their families there is nothing that I
can say that will heal anyone's pain but
I do want to express my sincere
condolences to everyone affected by this
terrible tragedy
Simone also asked that everyone please
respect her family's privacy as they
deal with their pain Tevin who's in the
army remains in custody in Georgia where
he's stationed he's awaiting extradition
to Ohio for arraignment on September
13th Simone and her only biological
brothers last post together was in 2017
the same year she competed on Dancing
with the Stars and got emotional
revealing their tough upbringing it's
been very hard because they block a lot
of things out from my childhood
Symone who's known for her mental
toughness has opened up to ET in the
past about dealing with her emotions I
wouldn't say I'm a super emotional
person but certain things make me
emotional but most of the time I try to
bottle up my emotions because I don't
like showing them necessarily like I
hate crying I hate it
so I bottle up all of that and then I
finally have like a mental breakdown and
I can't stop crying
you
you